how can we have so many devices with so
many apps which help us monitor our
progress for our body
but none for the soul well the qurani
app is about to show you your progress
with your soul
yes that's correct not only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hasanah counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah's book like you've
never had before
before the video starts guys i've come
together muslim made once again to get
to clean water
for families in gaza 105 pounds can
provide
interrupted water to two families for an
entire year give even if it's one pound
towards it
[Music]
take five all right go take five
assalamu alaikum
because it's our fifth take hopefully
this won't be right so as you can see
we've got new glasses
okay we've also got some new stuff to
tell you guys from the prophet muhammed
peace be upon him
now how does the prophet salallahu is
giving a direct message to the england
team but specifically these three
individuals who took the penalty who
took the risk
and went out there and put their neck on
the line sancho
rashford sucker that's correct these
three individuals
came up and they did what no one would
have wanted to do
but it came at a cost it could have come
at a
good price but it came at a cost as well
because um who was
their coach was it gareth gareth
southgate gareth southgate so he at one
point in his life
penalty as well right yeah in fact he
was the scapegoat that from his time
yeah that's when people started it
started becoming a big thing so he was
like the
all right the kind of emblem for being
blamed for miss penalty there you go so
it must be really like a nightmare for
him to
see or maybe try to prove a point he did
good he brought them to the finals etc
however
people are not talking about him
bringing them to the
finals they're talking about him not
winning the cop and the same with these
three football players
and maybe the england team as a whole
people are not pleased with them
now the question that we need to ask
ourselves is the following why are they
not pleased with them because if you
think about it
like we speak about sometimes we magnify
our mistakes or the things that go wrong
but we do not magnify our achievements
and we don't
spend enough time celebrating them now
the prophet peace be upon him said and
this is
uh narrated by ashleigh and him the
message of allah peace and blessings
will
upon him said whoever seeks the pleasure
of allah god
by the displeasure of people allah
suffice him against the people
whoever seeks the pleasure of the people
by the displeasure of allah
allah will leave him to the patronage of
people maybe this is
different we can use but basically the
people will not be pleased with them and
allah will not be pleased with them yeah
now in this very instance we do know
that we do not know the connection with
god almighty we do not know
however the point is very clear because
i can kind of resonate to them
in the context where in jahidia i would
have to prove myself to a lot of people
and i felt like an absolute slave and
these people would never be happy with
me
it's like making a wedding i don't know
you can be related with asian weddings
the aunties and uncles are never going
to be happy
there's always going to be something too
spicy too sweet
too hot too cold too bright too dark
yeah so whatever you do i've realized
that no one is
ever going to be happy with you aki now
with these people
you can see forget not being happy
someone can say you know what oh man why
did that happen forget that man
this outright racism it's like look
don't thank me
but don't spam me like you know don't
insult me at least you know i don't want
your fan
but at least don't come and insult me
now one thing that i want to touch upon
brothers and sisters is very important
brothers and sisters i've lived in
jahlia life before i came to islam
and i had times where i wanted to please
um um
people yeah okay i wanted to prove my
point to people and always
try to please them now brothers and
sisters what i've realized is that you
are never ever going to make people
happy and the prophet muhammad peace be
upon him
said and i shall have narrated that he
said if you was to try to please people
if not if you try to please allah wa
ta'ala rather than the people
allah subhanahu wa tala will be happy
with you and the people will be happy
with you
if you was to try to please the people
at the cost of uh pleasing allah
then neither allah would be happy with
you and neither the people would be
happy with your wrong sisters the hadith
a nutshell says that and this is a
message that we want to send through the
prophet muhammad peace be upon him
to these three football players you will
never ever make anyone happy
never ever anyone that loves you is a
conditional love
this goes to your wife this goes to your
mom dad whoever it may be
there's conditional love yes mom and dad
might be
not necessarily but even to a certain
point in the day judgment is peak times
so what what we're saying brothers and
sisters is that everyone loves you
conditionally
if you speak to someone and be like oh
yeah like for example let's say you're
married and like you know my in-law
and my mother-in-law unless they really
loves me i'm talking about someone else
yeah
really loves you yeah but if you used to
upset a daughter
that's conditional now or for example
you used to do something
or she's whatever it may be there's
always conditional love
brothers and sisters and this is a
message to every single one of us don't
please others because wallahi this is
something that allah has placed in us
like allah says in the quran
indeed with my remembrance to heart find
peace what that means that's a
metaphysical law
allah put in place when allah says
sadaqah doesn't make you poor
that's a metaphysical reality it's not
something you can touch
how could giving not make you poor if
you logically think you give
it doesn't make you poor how cannot
given not make you poor this is a
metaphysical reality
allah is talking about they're talking
about that's not empirical that you have
to believe in
the same goes with this allah has put in
place
that no one will ever be pleased with
you
period it's it's like a code it's like
you know you put code and because the
robot has to do this and this
like if you do this in a game for
example if you if your play gets it too
many times it dies
it's being programmed like that that
doesn't change if you get hit you're
going to die it's not going to be up
here
you're not going to understand of course
yeah but the point is this allah has set
that in place meaning
that no one whatever at the if
especially at the cost of allah
by necessity and his [ __ ] is that
they're never going to be happy with you
and now
that is actually a blessing why because
now when you realize and say for example
i've done this and this for that person
but he threw it back in my face
i went and did this this and this for
this person and they let me down you
know you get some people like
you know i'm going to treat everyone
like crap and that's the only extreme
you go to yeah
why oh because you've had so much bad
experience you're like you know what
forget this now i've tried being nice to
everybody
and people are just walking all over the
minute
[Music]
[Laughter]
ban them i'm bad everyone yeah now the
point is this what does what should that
make one realize
that should make one video i saw in a
second there must be someone that i
could love
that loves me unconditionally and if i
please him
that there is nothing but goodness and
this allah period so what allah has done
is via this metaphysical law is telling
you they're never going to be happy with
you and the fact that they're going to
let you down
is to push you it's up to you to push
you closer to allah so you can say you
know what man
i've tried pleasing and i'll be honest
try this taxation i thought you know i
forget that
once i freed myself from the people and
i said i don't care
and that's why aki before like i said
before i've done pictures
like i tell people i do uber i do i
drive a toyota prius yeah
some people might be like oh my god you
know and i'm like no
because i love that freedom to go and
say you know what i drive to her to
place oh for example i drive a bike
i drop back you know what i've got shoes
and they've got holes in it have you
seen my dreams
yeah not that kind of funny let's not
get some i'm going to try to think i was
poking them
yeah exactly yeah i walked the point is
not i'm not saying go walk around with
things the point is this
i don't care what anybody says yaki i
freed myself from the people
and i'm not saying i'm super racist what
i'm trying to see is the sweetness
don't tell i'm just trying to be humble
here okay i don't know
i'm not sure the point is this yet is
that the sweetness you feel aki
that you don't give a damn he thinks
that of me
i don't care can do you know what kind
of a freedom that exactly
do you know how liberating that is to
know that you can come out and you're
covered in the hijab of the jibba for
the sake of allah and you don't give a
damn of
i might look ugly i need to get my lips
filled i need to get my backside filled
i need to get here
and the brothers have to go get this
done some problems in germany uh
they're plucking the eyebrows no no
sisters the brothers are practicing
their eyebrows yeah
the point is this you will taste the
sweetness of iman
so with this what have you had if you
have you ever had
experience like this and what advice
would you give to the
free football the these three
individuals that you mentioned
because this is a very important thing
because when one
attaches their heart why is it important
for one to focus
on pleasing god almighty rather than
focusing on pleasing people
that's a very good point not only i've
never had the experience for playing for
in
england and taking a penalty and
missing the penalty i've never had that
experience in my life
but um the the principle remains the
same whatever the situation that we're
in
and the principle it reminds me of the
father the son and the donkey
oh right i never i don't know who's that
you probably do know yeah
there's one thing really bugging me
though there's a giant finger
mark on your left on your right lens
it's my fingerprint okay
it's identifying can we just get it
cleaned okay why are you talking i'll do
that let me see
yeah on the right oh there it is yeah so
there's there's my bad breath will kill
it straight away it might break the
glasses
oh it's cracking oh australia yeah the
so there's a father there's a son
and there's a donkey first the father
sits on the donkey
and the son rides alongside the dog and
then people say look how disrespectful
the sun is
yeah yeah his father's on the donkey
then i'm just gonna abridge it quickly
then
then the uh father is walking and the
sun is on there yeah did i say that
already
yeah yeah then the sun is on there then
they're like look how
uh look how spoiled the child is that
the father's walking
and the sun's on the donkey yes then
they both are get off the donkey
then they're like look there no one's
making the most of this donkey
and when they're both on it they say oh
they have no mercy on the animal they
have no mercy
anymore then the father gets angry then
he puts a donkey on his back
and then he's like maybe people are
going to be happy now then he walks past
a few more people look how crazy this
guy is he doesn't even know how to make
the most of this donkey that's very true
so
you're never going to be able to please
people but the thing with
like you said very very well and the
thing is sometimes as footballers or
people that are in a certain career
we get we get consumed by
just building yeah like you said we
don't celebrate we're like okay
uh we need to get scouted okay we got
scouted now we need to get selected for
a team okay we got selected for our team
now we need to get to the national team
okay now we need to uh win uh this cup
then we need to now be selected for this
there's always going to be achievements
and i'm sure as football players you
guys are not strangers to this but the
but the key
message and the takeaway here is racism
yeah what does islam say about racism
the prophet sallallahu alaihi from the
last
speech of course he's his life
is absolutely covered with issues in
which he
cut racism from the root in fact muslims
enter any masjid go to any mosque and
you will see people standing
shoulder to shoulder yeah in any salah
regardless of a king or a pauper a black
man or a right man
yeah you get no priority based upon your
race
uh about who you're praying with or who
you're being led
by it depends only on your deeds
only on your deeds it doesn't matter
about your race
yeah islam doesn't give superiority over
you know of of races of money and stuff
like this the only superiority that
you'll get
is your deeds you could be a football
player however if there's a farmer
that's doing more deeds than you then he
is better than you in the sight of allah
yeah you could be a footballer you're
doing all of this but you're giving in
charity
you're obeying allah has as you to be
obeyed you then better than
you know other people as well so the
point is
no matter what situation you're in don't
forget your lord because your lord will
keep you grounded
that should be your yardstick in life if
your yard is yardstick is
england fans you know you've seen the
england fans they will abandon you if
you don't get the penalties exactly what
mesut ozil said
yeah when i score i'm a german when i
miss then i'm an immigrant
yeah you guys saw this as well the way
you were tossed aside and this is the
thing when you put your reliance on the
people
yeah the people they just need from you
yeah
and sometimes even our families can fall
within that as well
but the only one that doesn't need
anything from us you tell anything we
are you're you're a great person
brother i'm nothing but when you say
this to allah oh oh
oh allah you're great then allah says
yes yes yes i'm great
humbleness is not befitting of allah
yeah so that's why when it comes to
relationship and putting our hope and
our trust and stuff like this
no matter where you are if you're
watching and you're a fan the same
message for you if you're watching
you're a footballer this defining
this this message is for you as well
that all of us we need allah allah
doesn't need
us and whichever if you're a footballer
you have
greater facilities yeah you you have
luxury you have time
that you can get and you can read the
quran
make that decision for yourself and you
have many uh players leicester city
hamza children mo salah pogba
yeah we have a lot of high profile stars
speak to them engage with them discuss
yeah you don't have to put everything in
the public sphere but
please don't waste your life yeah and
don't rely on these moments yes
if england had won you guys would be
hailed as heroes
but racism and people waiting for your
next slip
would still have been there bro sisters
there's nothing else to be said